happy birthday happy birthday yeah
Cheers a heart definitely in order
because gin is turning 27 on December
4th and the BTS army is going all-out
of course yeah truly BTS has the best
fans ever
basically the Army has planned out a
whole week to celebrate Jen the movement
is called Jin Festa 2019 they've got a
whole hashtag and everything seriously
look at some of these tweets and here's
how they are celebrating on November
27th they celebrated day one with Jin's
heart events from there they celebrated
his covers and songs and paid homage to
eat Jin fans also held streaming parties
for both tonight
we got it God know your head
and awake
[Music]
and today December 3rd is all about
preparing projects and letters for Jin
like I said best fans ever thank you for
those or the Emmys I love you and in
theme we also decided to find some of
our favorite gin moments from
compilations that you guys made
worldwide the handsome you know and of
course our favorite moment when et
interviewed all the guys back in 2017
what do you guys see the group and BTS
in 10 years you'll be uncle BTS uncle
and finally if you guys could say
anything to your younger selves you know
when you were just starting the groove
what would it be
please change your name alright guys
that is it for today a huge happy
birthday to Jin and of course for all
the latest on BTS stick with all things
et until next time I'm Katie Krauss and
bye for now
[Music]